tout le monde sait ce que je pense pas
qu'on tire la cop15 géo +1 sur un jeu où
nous sommes finalement des autruches
alors comment tu le vis à des chéneaux
touche actuellement jojo bah ouais j'ai
l'impression de servir d'or quoi fc tu
vois mais ça marche bien ça marche bien
fall et on s'en va alors le but c'est
privé pour pérenniser c'est exactement
ça alors joints des u13 royaume quoi
ouais enfin avec les cuisses l'autruche
et rigole pas abrasive a dit qu'à
quelques pas de là au michigan des
[ __ ] de points que je ne sais pas
pourquoi
en quatre ans au népal plus vous gagnez
des points avec allégresse et julio
segura ça c'est le petit et c'est le jeu
le plus péter du monde mais il faudrait
des even quoi est fait couler le bateau
huawei attends je t'ai suite on peut pas
se casser le premier mec et notre coup
et cheikh lô dinosaures oh là là j'ai
trois grosses têtes avec et d'ange et
italiennes mais relève divin à 9 de tort
bien ta dedans vie s'est-il en il en
fait un bon boulot mais on peut passer
d'îles en îles très bien à histoire de
bien [ __ ] absolument toute la planète
terre à coups de deux cuisses d'autruche
c'est normal voilà tout va bien à temps
on peut le reprendre de trek a laissé
battant viens on va te tuer par là bas
mais là faut faire du faux faire la maca
si non tu es mort non non je hathaway
géo l'herbe et j'ai perdu élevé à la 3e'
d'accord ah ouais [ __ ] tu as carrément
raison un lycée de boeuf c'est beau
c'est lui qui a fait de jeu avec alors
ils vont casser le palais pour faire des
ponts un bon ça marche c'est bon oui à
l'arrivée hall arriver à temps à la
mecque la mecque j'ai un bol peppers
alors voilà pour tous ceux qui veulent y
aura ce volpé peu en téléchargement dans
la description bêta père d'une fille du
staff technique
je suis tombé dans l'eau à temps si je
récapitule on est des [ __ ] d'autrui
sur des îles perdues ou quand tu tapes
dans des trucs à des mules qui est
pourquoi il a un chapeau lübeck
et bien voilà mon jeu a craché du coup
tu attends un chocolat dans la gorge à
ça pas du tout mon jeu a craché donc on
doit tout recommencer
mais rassurez vous on a quand même gardé
de lunettes ah ah ah c'est bon on y va
en speed run voilà on est des jeux on
est des gens ne devaient plus tôt ce
mois-ci gérer ce type
je vais chercher le de toi quand tu fais
une blague nul c'est comme ça que tu te
rattrape genre assez tôt me pète mois
attends je vais chercher neuf mois je
vais direct aux bulles mais qu est ce qu
on lit bull sur la bas vas-y vas-y
j'arrive j'arrive et ben pète ça fera
des bulles
allez on va au 4 mai non c'est pas ça
[ __ ] mais j'ai me paye une multi leur
mère vous allez qu'il arrive à rager
tout seul serge aux autruches qui a les
regardes tu vois le portail là il est
dysfonctionnel ouais voilà bah va dedans
non non c'est bon ah t'es qu'une
autruche mouillé fait du bruit pour
cette blague non merci
faites du bruit pour les autres merci
c'est la fameuse hymne du squelette
exactement il va revenir on y va on y va
on y va on y va on y va on y va on y va
je répète je répète t on sur le côté à
merde côté en fait d'un mec qui m'a tuer
actions qu il paye tout net quoi comme
jeu et ma grosse tête d'autriche qui
dépasse brouillard quoi aller mais bon
nickel moi je t'attendais à l'aller plus
veja l'autruche
tassotti taf est allé vite fait un salto
que attention faites du bruit pour les
autres
auch den broeck fait cette blague tourne
tellement rien à dire sur le jeu de
merde qu'au final ça a fait du bruit
merci pourquoi est ce que mon jeu est
passé à 30 fps
ouais moi aussi j'ai jamais eu une
petite baisse de framerate c'est à dire
que le jeu est trop mal fait quoi ouais
du bruit coucou au hockey le squelette
il court mais j'ai jamais vu un
squelette aussi un mec on trouve les
bulles et en se cassant est bien
d'accord on fait du bruit pour l'heure
il faut que j'arrête
attention j'ai vu l'ombre d'un squelette
là par là c'est aussi book battlefield
quand même extrêmement bien sûr cache
toi moi c'était chaud
où sont ces [ __ ] de bull a l'air tue
c'est ridicule je t'entends spam et
oncle y en a même perdu dans un bar un
labyrinthe avec des autruches cause dans
un bois à thaon sur skate au vivat porte
à porte et se passer on de silence au
mec est un squelette cela est bien joli
gâteau ce que tu attends qu assez bon je
crois que j'ai trouvé où il faut aller à
jive au fils de [ __ ] tu aimerais tu
avais aller dans l'eau est le squelette
mongai l'agent ferrari je te jure c'est
un truc de ou tard j'aurai non mais il
manque encore des fous c'est en ce jour
je pète des câbles ont pas passer l'eau
at en boîte en boîte en bois sans doute
à la presse
j'en ai marre il vient enfin versée par
là je suis fait arranger came down n'est
qu'un jeu d'autruche ça marche tant
ouais c'est bon c'est bon moi aussi je
suis non alors bon réservé à cet écran
d'accueil
bonsoir nous sommes
les autruches devant ça va bah ça va
chambon pas oui lui pardonnerai jamais
cru autruches cellule je sais est
actionnaire à plus 10 sport doit ses one
man show s'il vous plaît oui oui non la
vieille tête de tricherie des vases
grecs mais [ __ ] je suis bloqué dans le
trou mais j'ai porté ma tête dans le
coffre
attends attends attends je te fait la
courte échelle
vas-y vas-y d'accord ok à ezo trouver
l'énigme apprend des gamins de 8 ans de
madame haman mana mana mana et où depuis
quand je me fais violer par des
squelettes quoi je me fais gong gong par
les squelettes
je t'attends je t'attends ok d'accord
c'est roach et entame mais attends tu
passes dans l'hôpital des pierres sur
les pieds doit lancer le poids des pires
ces grosses moules en fait assez des
moulins voulons au nom de viol est aussi
bon pour commencer les leviers
madame a oh là là là là je vais à lola
coucou à mes fils de [ __ ] tu m'attends
dans un cul de sac
je suis passé je t'attends c'est pas
possible quoi c'est oh oui oh et c'est
le tranche george ados l'autriche c'est
long mais j'arrivais pas sauter au
dessus quoi
[ __ ] c'est rien c'est abusé ce jeu
mais les verts assez bon mais comment tu
as fait pour passer au tus un peu et
bien mis au bord un
le plan rouge à la hausse est bon ou les
bulles vient c'est bon voilà sa part li
jian a job à temps bien fait à d'accord
ok ya des trous il ya des trous dans
l'eau que tu feras attention game over
d'ailleurs pouvoir commencer j'aime
quand c'est que je suis bon sens ne sais
pas comment je suis vite
oh merde adema 40 est mort c'est
vraiment cette scène est ridicule
vraiment la courte échelle de trait
jusqu'à vas-y je te fais la course
suivante
mais on attend tous à l'udc a bien
rappelé à wen je vous dis au revoir tout
le monde mais ce n'est pas gagné cette
vidéo
et puis voilà bientôt salut
à